Whoopi Goldberg teases an update on the
highly anticipated Sister Act 3 movie
We're In It we're we are so close but
it's you know when you have 9 000 people
who have to okay it it takes a little
more time than you want but it's coming
which Echo is what she recently told E.T
I've been trying to do this for six
years six years and I'd been told that
no one was interested in seeing what it
was like my all-time favorite movie The
Original who of course people are
interested in saying this it takes a
minute for people to realize they should
take their foot out of their mouth yeah
well you got it out and it's coming out
soon right it's kind of we got to shoot
it but it's it's gonna it's happening
are you happy with the script you're
never fully happy with the script really
yeah because one of the things that you
find is you want to have the space to
make an adjustment if you need to fair
enough and so sometimes what looks right
on paper doesn't come out of your mouth
the right way so you have to just kind
of
description kind of moving around a
little bit but I'm very hopeful
that people will be happy
and fans have a lot to look forward to
for the View's big return for season 26.
well we're back and we're back at the
table to kick off
season 26.
it's I like to be as surprised as you
all are when I come back to work so I
don't know what's new other than the two
new co-hosts but you know it's going to
be us trying to not
implode on the show and and just helping
people figure out
the things that maybe they have
questions about so
[Music]